un mot sur la sur eric coquerel lui-même
puisque vous avez sans doute entendu
hier un rokhaya diallo qui dit avoir
plusieurs sources au sein de la france
en sont bis parler du comportement
inapproprié d'eric coquerel avec les
femmes elle saisit du coup sûr prises
par votre choix de le nommer à la
commission des finances est ce que vous
aviez des informations sur un
comportement inapproprié d'eric coquerel
n'ont aucunement il ya eu hier
d'ailleurs vous savez on a une cellule
en charge des violences sexistes et
sexuelles au sein de la france est
soumise cette cellule a publié un
communiqué hier soir disant les choses
devenir très clair et factuel il n'ira
et aucun signalement témoignages qui a
été adressé à cette cellule donc jamais
rien entendu jamais parlé de ça je je je
lis comme tout le monde les rumeurs sur
les réseaux sociaux et la jeu j'observe
que ces rumeurs sont relayées dans la
presse jeudi que le sujet de la lutte
contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles est un sujet trop sérieux pour
être livré uniquement aux rumeurs qui
circulent sur les réseaux sociaux sans
aucun témoignage concret donc les choses
elles sont très claires si au madame
rokhaya diallo dispose de témoignages de
personnes qui mettent en cause telle ou
telle personne pas uniquement ce député
mais telle ou telle personne membre de
la france a soumis jeudi a dressé les a
au comité de lutte contre les violences
sexistes et sexuelles qui a été mis en
place au sein de la france a soumis 6 et
des actes répréhensibles a dressé les à
la justice
existe
enfin je sais pas je parle pas de ce
sujet spécifique de manière générale on
a toujours fonctionné de cette manière
et on a une attention très importante à
ces questions qui sont des questions
très sensibles de lutte contre les
violences sexistes et sexuelles je
rappelle quand même ici que il ya
quelques mois nous avons en trois jours
suite à des signalements qui avaient été
adressées à cette cellule décidé qu'un
candidat qui était candidat aux
élections législatives ne l'était plus
donc on peut pas
deux procès sur ce sujet mais attention
au temps on est très sérieux sur ce
sujet autant justement parce qu'on est
très sérieux sur ce sujet ça peut pas
être les rumeurs sur les réseaux sociaux
sans aucun signe ce témoignage concret
aucune preuve aucun aucun signalement
qui fasse office d'information donc là
il faut être un peu sérieux sur le sujet
parce que sinon ça veut dire qu'il ya
aussi des personnes qui sont livrés en
quelque sorte à la vindicte des réseaux
sociaux alors que ça ne s'appuient pas
sur des témoignages concrets la
sénatrice mélanie vogel qui prône une
personne à l'opposition elle vous
demande des clarifications qu'est ce que
vous lui dites est ce que ça peut
fragiliser la nuit belge et de les
clarifications elle n'a été donnée il y
à une cellule cette cellule a fait un
communiqué il n'y a aucun témoignage qui
n'a jamais été adressées à cette cellule
points
[Musique]